so every now and then I like to do
things to surprise my friends and the
people who work with me and one of my
favorite websites to do that with its
fiber and its fiber calm and it's
basically things that people will do for
five bucks and some of the things are
pretty crazy pretty wild things you'd
never think of and one of them was
there's a guy named Jason who will call
people call your friends whoever you
want as Morgan Freeman if you pay in
five bucks so I thought you know what
I'm gonna I'm going to try this out on
some of my friends and and this is a
result yes hi there Steve sorry oh my
name is Morgan Freeman listen I'm
calling on behalf of Evan Carmichael my
name is Oh fine Sharon you're probably
wondering why I'm phoning you but a good
friend of mine Evan Carmichael asked me
to phone you say thank you for all your
help with the mastermind group and also
for helping inspire the next generation
of entrepreneurs oh no how it's done no
I know him but he's a little racy for my
taste listen uh friend of mine wanted me
to phone you and let you know that you
are the world's greatest salsa
instructor we met a few years ago on
seven he wanted me to phone you and tell
you that you're the best fantasy
copywriter in the world oh that's
awesome thank you so much for calling
london he wanted me to say thank you for
being a great guy to host a website with
and for all the fantastic service now I
before I go on now maybe I'm just too
old but when I was your age we didn't
have DJ ducks you know we had James
Brown and the temptations and I don't
know what's going on with this world
that's awesome I really appreciate the
concept you're very welcome Steve enjoy
the rest of your day thank you so much
for God appreciate okay bye now
you